here go for the steal first you can get  an eight-second violation if you're  careful  westbrook just realized that it's  deflected and stolen easy  basemore's got it put ahead to wiggins  and he  missed the land no the chance to tie the  game  and that will do it ah it was right  there  and it went off iron well if  if he misses the free throw one of them  then you still got a chance  maybe a one possession game but andrew  wing is gonna want this one back that  was a tough pass looked like  raul nedo had a chance at that when it  got through  and hung on the rim for about 30 seconds  it seemed like  he was jumping from so far out just  the angle off the backboard didn't  get it exactly like he wanted it to so  bartons  he makes the second one and you're done  shoots it at 88 from the line  [Applause]  and makes them both  so